l'institut d'etudes politiques sciences
po s'installe dans les yvelines dès
septembre 2014 c'est à saint germain en
laye que la célèbre filière accueillera
une promotion de 80 étudiants une
journée portes ouvertes permettait ce
samedi de venir se renseigner et
s'inscrire au concours de la formation
sciences po une formation que l'institut
tente depuis des années de démocratiser
afin de l'ouvrir au plus grand nombre on
a mis en place un système de préparation
dans des lycées publics 1,2 des
territoires plutôt défavorisés qui là
encore est destiné à adil on a aidé les
enfants qui pensent pas forcément à
passer ce type de concours et qui n'ont
pas forcément au départ les ressources
pour le réussira à le faire
la formation sciences po se déroule en
cinq ans avec deux premières années
généraliste et une troisième année à
l'étranger en 4e année l'étudiant se
spécialiser effectué des stages dans la
branche qui l'a sélectionné la cinquième
année s'effectuera à l'université de
versailles saint quentin ou de
cergy-pontoise deux établissements
partenaires afin d'offrir un choix plus
varié pour les masters 2 désormais sans
faire sciences po paris les étudiants
yvelinois ne manqueront donc de rien
le premier atout de cette super c'est sa
situation géographique puisque il ainsi
en région parisienne et que j'habite en
parisienne donc ça m'intéresse
mais aussi parce qu'il est associé à des
à des universités qui sont assez
reconnus en france les locaux cesserez
ans qui m'a impressionné en premier
parce qu'ils sont vrais enfin vraiment
très beau et on sait que dans des locaux
comme ça qu'on a vraiment facilement
envie de travailler les inscriptions au
concours sont ouvertes depuis le 3
février se clôtureront le 18 avril si
les étudiants boursiers sont exemptés de
frais de scolarité les plus favorisés
payeront eu 4000 euros l'année à terme
sciences po saint germain en laye
devrait accueillir près de 700 élèves
non